just over 20 years ago together they
formed Cisco Systems I think I was very
frustrated
Len was as frustrated but probably kind
of quieter about it
[Music]
these two right here stole Cisco from
Stanford University well immoral this is
nothing out of the ordinary within the
business world for example Mark stole
Facebook from the Winkle wasp twins in
Divya Narendra Zuckerberg decided to
steal their ideas in the business plan
and Steve Jobs stole the Mac from Xerox
for people who kept bugging me that
ought to get my rear over to Xerox Park
and see what they were doing and the
Bill Gates stole Windows also from Xerox
Facebook apple and Microsoft are all
multi-hundred billion if not
multi-trillion dollar companies today so
clearly the punishment for stealing
ideas isn't all that high in the
business World worst case scenario you
might have to pay 65 million to settle a
lawsuit but this wasn't the case with
Cisco you see like the other victims
Stanford wasn't really able to do
anything about Cisco through the legal
system they thought about filing
criminal charges against the founders
but they figured that it would just be a
better idea financially and stress wise
to just license the technology to Cisco
themselves at this point Cisco's
Founders probably thought that they were
in the clear but karma often Works in
weird ways Cisco's Founders would end up
losing the entire company to a predatory
VC firm normally you might feel bad for
these people but in this case they
really just got a taste of their own
medicine not to mention it it was it
them who brought in these PC Partners so
really there's no one to blame but
themselves by far the worst part about
all of this is that Cisco actually ended
up doing extraordinarily well under VC
leadership in fact in the 10 years after
the founders were pushed out Cisco would
grow from being a couple hundred million
dollar company to being the world's
largest company at least the founders
must have gotten a massive payday thanks
to their stake in the company right
psych they actually sold their entire
stake for peanuts when they were pushed
out of the company out of resentment
clearly they didn't enjoy being on the
victim side of having Cisco stolen so
here's the insane story of how this
couple tried to pull a quick one on
Stanford only to have a quick one pulled
on themselves
taking a look back the story of Cisco
can be traced back to a couple named
Leonard Bosak and Sandy Lerner naturally
they were both Highly Educated
individuals Leonard had a bachelor's in
engineering from the University of
Pennsylvania and a masters in computer
science from Stanford it was while he
was pursuing his Masters that he got the
opportunity to work on a special
university project
the project entailed a connecting
Stanford's computer science wing and a
businesswing through a network so that
data can easily be communicated between
the two hey isn't that Cisco's entire
business mod anyway it was also around
this time that he met Sandy Lerner who
was also pursuing her own masters in
statistics and computer science at
Stanford the two would get married
almost instantly and they would both get
jobs at Stanford after graduation
Leonard would become the director of the
computer science wing for Stanford's
business school and Sandy would have
become the director of the computer
science Wing firsthand for his computer
science department most couples would
call it right here but that was easier
said than done for Sandy and Leonard due
to their jobs they were constantly
coming across the smartest engineers in
the world and their latest inventions
which created a lot of Temptations one
such Temptation was the blue box created
by Andy bechtelsheim and William Yeager
the blue box was a simple multi-protocol
router but back in the early 90s 80s
this was the voodoo magic that was
connecting Stanford's various
departments
with this in the real world but
unfortunately this wasn't possible
Stanford had made it explicitly clear
that the blue box was for internal use
only this applied to even the original
founders in fact William Yeager claims
that his request to commercialize The
Invention was outright denied but it
doesn't seem like this denial put off
Leonard all that much in 1985 Leonard
would join forces with another Stanford
employee named Kirk Lockheed and the two
would basically rip off Eager software
to create Cisco iOS and with that Cisco
was born but not everyone was happy with
the company Stanford wasn't naturally
Furious they had specifically told even
a co-founder to not commercialize the
product
yet here they were dealing with a couple
of Hot Head recent graduates trying to
rip off the tech I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that Leonard didn't
keep his job at Stanford for much longer
Stanford would turn around and threaten
to foul criminal complaints against
Cisco for theft of software hardware and
other intellectual property
but after thinking about it for some
time Stanford decided to not pursue this
round the reality was that it would be
Stanford who would have to deal with
years of lawsuits to prove their case
just to win a Pity settlement from Cisco
so Stanford made the smarter choice and
decided to just license the tech to
Cisco in 1987.
at this point they couldn't stop Cisco
from commercializing the tech so they
might as well profit from it Leonard and
Sandy probably thought that they were in
the clear but they had yet to face the
real predator
by 1987 just two years after the company
was founded Cisco was pulling in nearly
2 million dollars per month in Revenue
originally the people buying their
Network Technology was a research
Center's government facilities and
universities but slowly more and more
companies became interested and they
started making big orders
well this was a great news for the
company it was also terrible news
because fulfilling these orders was much
easier said it than done unlike startups
today who can just go to the entire
world using insanely powerful Cloud
computers Cisco had to scale the
old-fashioned way after all they were
producing physical routers and
networking gear so they had to deal with
suppliers manufacturers Logistics
scaling and inventory and all of that
this is hard enough for a consumer
company to deal with so I think you can
imagine how hard it was for a startup to
fulfill orders of ten thousand or thirty
thousand routers so Cisco really had no
choice but to raise venture capital
in 1988 they would approach the famous
Sequoia Capital to give them some extra
cash to grow their company
Sequoia would happily give them cash the
first time around but this cash didn't
even last 12 months and it wasn't long
until Cisco was asking Sequoia for more
which Sequoia wasn't exactly comfortable
with this was not long after Black
Monday so the stock market wasn't
exactly performing great not to mention
it Sequoia had it just to give him the
money for Sequoia to get even more
involved they needed more assurance that
this company would actually make it to
the other side so they proposed the deal
so Koya would continue funding Cisco if
Cisco gave them controlling voting power
and allowed for sequoia's founder Don
Valentine to become the chairman of the
company obviously this was a pretty
aggressive ask but Cisco had a no time
to shop around for more money it was
either take the deal with sequoia or
gamble with the company's life Leonard
and Sandy of course chose to take the
deal and from a financial perspective it
worked out great by 1989 Cisco would
expand to three products 111 employees
and a cold 27 million dollars in Revenue
but all of this of course came with a
price they now had to deal with Don
Valentine who wasn't exactly a friend
this isn't to say that Don didn't have
Cisco's best interest in mind the
problem was that that was the only
interest he had in mind frankly he
didn't care about Leonard or Sandy he
had poured a lot of money into the
startup and he was gonna make sure that
it panned out to increase the chances of
this happening he would go ahead and
hire a computer veteran named John
morrowgridge as the company's new CEO
Leonard would be demoted to the role of
Chief scientist which wasn't too bad
Sandy though was demoted to the role of
wait for it leading customer service at
this point Don Valentine was straight up
insulting the founders and the things
would only get worse
foreign
in February of 1990 Cisco would go
public and enjoy a roaring IPO the
company would close off the first day of
trading with a market cap of 224 million
dollars which made the founders sent to
millionaires not a bad sum of money but
the company was just getting started
they added just to barely escape the
funding Crunch and the companies were
just starting to leverage their Tech so
they had a bright future ahead in the
billions and the tens of billions but it
seems that Don may have had some
ulterior motives when it came to taking
Cisco public you see it Leonard and
Sandy now had an easy way to sell their
mistakes so it became that much easier
for Don to push out the founders and
that's exactly what he would do on
August 28 1990 Dawn and John would
straight up fire Sandy Leonard would
instantly resign in thinking that it
would be some sort of protest but Don
didn't give a crap the reality was that
Cisco didn't need Sandy or Leonard to be
successful after all they didn't even
invent the technology to make things
worse Don and John thought that Sandy
and Leonard were completely incompetent
in fact during Sandy's first meeting
with John he would tell her quote I hear
that you're everything that's wrong with
Cisco this bad blood only increased over
time as John felt that the founders had
no clue about sales he felt that the
only reason Cisco was even able to grow
so far was thanks to companies that
would go out of their way to have the
latest and the greatest Cisco was by no
means appealing to the average company
which is where the money really was and
considering that Cisco would literally
grow a thousand decks over the past 10
years Andrea's leadership it looks like
he was right so to be honest when
Leonard resigned Donna probably didn't
think oh no I lost a co-founder instead
he probably thought great two birds with
one stone Leonard and Sandy should have
taken the hint stepped away and just
enjoyed their lives but they wanted to
send Don a message that they didn't need
Cisco either and with that they would go
ahead and sell their entire 66 stake for
170 million dollars that may have felt
good at the time but it was objectively
a brain dead decision I mean it's not
like they needed the money or that they
didn't believe in the future of the
company there was literally nothing to
say a lot other than ego and resentment
and they would be the ones who ended up
paying the price Ten Years Later Cisco
would have become the world's largest
company with a market cap of 569 billion
dollars this means that there are 66
stake would have been worth 375 billion
even if we assume that they sold off of
46 of their stake the remaining 20 would
be worth over a hundred billion yup and
they done deadly do it screwed up
shortly after the host disco Fiasco
Sandy and Leonard's marriage would also
fall apart and this was really The Rock
Bottom for these two but I do gotta say
they did pull themselves back up and
focused on giving away the money that
they did receive they would donate 70 of
the proceeds to Charities focused on
promoting animal welfare and science
projects if you ask the duo about Cisco
today they have some pretty diverse
answers Leonard plays it off pretty cool
and simply says that they walked away
with a bunch of money anyways so there's
nothing to regret as for Sandy however
she is understandably still pretty
triggered about the situation Len and I
underestimated our skills I certainly
could have run that business I had my
hands on the reins if you're wondering
what happened to the original founders
of the blue box well Andy bechtelsheim
would go on to found some Microsystems
and he now boasts in that worth of over
10 billion dollars
so looks like he didn't need a blue box
to make it big
the only ones regretting their choices
today is the ones who tried stealing do
you think that Leonard and Sandy just
got what they deserved comment that down
below also drop a like if you're happy
for Andy and of course consider checking
out our Discord community so just for
the video ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
thank you
foreign